foreign
[Applause]
thank you and welcome again
um not only is the universe Stranger
than we think it is Stranger than we can
think so argued Niels Bohr one of the
founders of quantum of theory
we imagine our theories uncover how
things are
but from Quantum particles to Dark
Matter Mata at fundamental levels the
closer we get to what we imagine to be
the reality The Stranger and more
incomprehensible it appears to become
might find some philosophy one day
stretch to meet the universe is
strangeness
or is the universe not so strange after
all
or should we give up the idea that we
can uncover the essential character of
the world and with ball conclude that
the strangeness of the universe and the
quantum World transcend the limits of
the human mind
Bjorn eggburg is a philosopher of
science who researches the limits of
scientific knowledge he is the author of
metaphysical experiments physics and the
invention of the universe
Sabina hostfelder is a theoretical
physicist who specializes in the
foundations of physics husfelder has a
popular YouTube channel called science
without the gobbledygook
Rupert sheldrake is a biologist author
and researcher Rupert is author of books
like the science delusion and ways to go
beyond and why they work
so that's the
um the theme of the debate and our
speakers today
and what we're going to do is first of
all each of the speakers will respond to
a question that we're going to put them
and then we're going to go on to a more
fluid debate about some other issues so
the first question that I'm going to ask
all of our speakers to address
is might science and philosophy one day
stretch to meet the universe's
strangeness and to address this question
we're first going to ask Beyond
no
okay or let me Let me refresh to uh to
use a little bit more time I certainly
hope not uh what do we mean by
strangeness
uh in this context I understand
strangeness to be that which defies our
minds or that which we cannot understand
or which we cannot control with our own
rules of logic and reason
now certainly if you look at this
historically there's no shortage of
things that defy our minds or that defy
our understanding and uh this certainly
also persists into an age of increasing
Science and Technology we have this
general idea that science always
progresses and that we know things
better and better however this is not
always the case
uh
science can also get stuck in certain
patterns of thinking and it doesn't
always necessarily progress this is a
topic that I'll return to in another
talk later and I'm sure also in this
panel
but if we look at history and it's
showing us two things about strangeness
one is that we will keep failing at
understanding things
and the second thing is we will keep
trying to understand things because I
don't think we have any choice
so
I would like to think of strangeness for
this debate as not the antagonists that
we have to overcome I think strangeness
is the source of inspiration the endless
source of inspiration for our endeavors
in science and and philosophy so that's
why I say I hope that they never stretch
because what fun would be left if they
do
thank you Bjorn and next up might sound
some philosophy one day stretched to
meet the university strangeness over to
Sabina
yeah so I I have to start quite uh
similar to you uh in asking what do we
even mean by strangeness so um if we're
talking about the kind of strangeness
that we currently deal with like quantum
mechanics or dark matter then I'm
personally pretty confident we'll be
able to solve it with the methods that
we currently have it's just a matter of
trying a little bit harder but there are
other strangenesses where I'm not quite
as confident like when it comes to
question what is consciousness
so personally on that matter I think
we'll we'll eventually figure it out but
maybe I'm wrong and then there are other
questions where I'm like I'm not even
exactly sure what the question is like
uh why is the universe understandable at
all is this a question that we can even
formalize will we ever be able to
address it
but I think the the
thing that we should focus on is much
like uh he just said is how do we make
progress so
um historically we have made progress
by gradually building up our knowledge
we have learned a little bit more than
we made some new experiments and we
learned a little bit more and so I think
we have to try to continue this
progress
to learn more but it's quite possible
that at some point we just fail and then
we'll get stuck there and in that case
there will be some strangeness left for
us forever
thank you Sabina and now to Rupert my
science and philosophy one day stretch
to meet the universe's strangeness
well I'd say sounds and floss you've
already stretched a lot in relation to
the universe until the 1920s no one knew
there were galaxies outside our own
until the 1960s most scientists didn't
think that the Universe had evolved in
time from The Big Bang which is now an
orthodox Theory and so there's been a
huge expansion in our view of the
universe but all of this has happened
within the framework of mechanistic
materialism the doctrine that matter is
unconscious and that the everything's
caused mechanically in one way or
another
um governed by purposeless laws
I think one of the biggest challenges
for science as a whole at the moment is
the existence of consciousness
and most mechanistic materialists think
that Consciousness is absent from the
entire universe all the stars and
galaxies all the other planets
everything else except in a tiny tiny
fraction of matter namely human brains
and possibly animal brains as well
however and that leads to the so-called
hard problem of Consciousness to explain
Consciousness in the universe that's
otherwise unconscious
one way of tackling that is through the
rise in the philosophy of pan psychism
Which is surprisingly fashionable at the
moment and what pansakis says that well
if there's a little bit of Consciousness
in electrons and atoms then the effect
it emerges in human brains is just a
difference of degree not of kind
well I think that argument's all right
as far as it goes but I'm rather
interested in what happens if we take it
further instead of stopping at human
brains uh carry on into the universe and
I myself have been thinking for quite a
while about the question is the sun
conscious
can the sun be conscious does
Consciousness have to be confined to
brains the cerebrocentric view of
Consciousness we're very used to but
traditional peoples have always taken it
for granted that Consciousness is much
more extensive
Plato called the stars and the planets
the visible Gods because he thought they
had intelligence they were the bodies of
which they had intelligence as well
and um
I published a paper last year in the
Journal of Consciousness studies called
is the sun conscious
in which I argue that the interface
between the sun's activity and
Consciousness is its electromagnetic
field
this may sound strange but sitting right
next to me in the form of John Joe
McFadden is one of the principal
exponents of the electromagnetic field
of Consciousness his theory is largely
confined to brains he may be appalled at
this extension of it but I think it's
you can make a perfectly coherent case
that the sun has a conscious interface a
Consciousness interfacing with its body
through the electromagnetic field within
and Beyond the sun throughout the solar
system and if the sun's conscious what
about other stars if they're conscious
what about entire galaxies which may
have Galactic Minds vastly greater than
those of stars which are like cells in
the body of the Galaxy and then what
about the whole universe the cosmos
so leaving Consciousness out we get
contemporary cosmology and physics
putting Consciousness in we get a whole
new way of thinking about the universe
that may make it less strange because
our own Consciousness seems less
anomalous in in a con in a universe
pervaded by Consciousness then many
other questions arise if the sun's
conscious what does it do with its
Consciousness what decisions does it
make but my three minutes is almost up
so I'm not going to be able to tell you
my speculations on that subject or
anyone else's speculations but they may
come up later in our discussion but we
do have a few minutes left actually
because our our first speakers were very
succinct in their answers so we're gonna
I'm gonna stretch a little bit further
to press you on some questions the
question was about whether physics um as
science and philosophy can stretch now
we've spoken really mostly about
um science but is is one of the problems
that science generally since the days of
Descartes has generally drifted away
from philosophy do we need more
philosophy in science in order to try to
make sense of the world is there are we
missing something Beyond
I mean around the same time as physics
became professionalized and when
cosmology started coming into formation
as well philosophy went through its own
break into two camps so to speak their
philosophy also became professionalized
uh one part that was looking to be uh
useful and subservient to science to
clarify analytic terms and another part
that started wading into entirely
different questions some of them
bridging on what Rupert is talking about
but it strikes me that in the last
century we've had physics has tended to
be alone in setting the terms and
conditions for how to understand the
universe and that philosophy has either
been useless or left to the sidelines
more or less it would be my perspective
what do you think Sabina
do you need philosophy
well I do think physicists should pay a
little bit more attention to philosophy
because
there are a lot of questions where
philosophy becomes really important
where we get a little bit lost at the
moment for example the questions about
the origin of the universe is one of
them but also when it comes to the
question of whether a scientific
hypothesis has to be testable
um physicists I think don't quite get it
right yeah they insist on this notion of
testability but then they often think
that just because it's testable it's
also good science
which doesn't really work out in their
favor there are a lot there are a lot of
other examples where
it would have been good if physicists
have paid a little bit more attention to
philosophy interestingly enough since uh
dark matter is one of the examples of
strangeness that came up here is that
one of the best books I know about how
to make sense of Dark Matter comes from
a physicist and philosopher David
Merritt who tried to analyze the
different research programs as to how
how much progress they've made according
to certain philosophical approaches
okay thank you Sabrina
um and now I would like to move forward
onto the debate and we're going to be
looking at three questions
and the first question theme one is are
there limits to what humans can
understand
and first I'm going to give the floor to
Rupert to address this question
well obviously our limited Minds which
revolved largely through the stone ages
um it's rather it's rather surprising
that we can think about galaxies and
stars and and physical forces and
biological evolution and so on
um that our minds are limited in the way
they work and as the philosopher
Emmanuel Kant pointed out long ago the
way in which we think uh the the
categories of time space and causality
were his principal Focus
determine what we can think our minds
work in a particular way and we can only
think in particular ways and those might
not map onto the rest of the universe
however
the traditional View and for example in
medieval theology uh in say something
like Thomas Aquinas
is that our minds have a unique ability
to map onto and understand the universe
because they and the universe have a
common source namely God and that human
consciousness is like a scaled done we'd
now say fractile version of divine
Consciousness
um Divine Consciousness contains forms
patterns structures
understandings meanings and
um that our minds are adapted to that
because they have a common source to
Nature
in fact this is implicit in modern
science even though many modern
scientists are atheists the founding
fathers of modern science overall
interested in theology Newton Descartes
Galileo Kepler and others
um and they thought that the mind of God
worked mathematically
mathematicians love the idea that God is
a mathematician because of all people it
makes them closest to God and and the um
they thought that God was a
mathematician the mind of God determined
the structure of the universe through
mathematical laws and human Minds
through the gift of god-given gift of
reason as Descartes taught can
understand mathematics and understand
the universe through mathematics both
have their Source in the Divine mind so
Descartes in a sense was following a
traditional View
but when people in the 19th century when
materialism became the dominant Esau of
science people simply said well there's
no such thing as God or angels and human
minds are nothing but the product of
physical activity in the brain then they
destroyed this deep connection between
the universe and human Minds human Minds
then just became something had evolved
through
hunting William Amherst with stone
implements and things
um it's a much more limited view of
human minds but I think if we cover this
much larger view of Consciousness in the
universe and a larger view of the nature
of Consciousness then it's less
mysterious than it might otherwise be
yeah
may I ask you then a question because
you outlined here a sort of a pan
psychist view introducing Consciousness
into the mix and then a further
extension or an extreme version as you
say of that going even further with the
Sun
with this eliminate the sense of
strangeness if we understood
Consciousness to be everywhere is uh
because with Consciousness when we're
talking about understanding it's we
usually are confined to reason
irrationality which is only a tiny part
of Consciousness to some extent if we
allow for Consciousness to be everywhere
along the lines that you outline
would there still be strangeness
well it'd certainly be strangeness in
the sense that there'd be vast amounts
of the universe that are utterly
unfamiliar to us like distant galaxies
and other planets and
um there's plenty of strangeness here on
Earth if we think about the different
forms of life that exists in the deep
ocean or in the bacterial or fungal
world so just a wide variety of animals
and how they live and and plants I mean
there's plenty of strangeness here on
Earth if you think about it
um so I think there'd be plenty of
things that are unfamiliar to our minds
I mean even if a star is conscious it'd
be very difficult for us to understand
what it's like to be a star can I
interrupt you there talking about stars
I'll ask Sabine what do you think can a
star be conscious
um well depends on what you mean by
conscious so I mean so so the question
was are there limits to what humans can
understand uh and I think the answer is
obviously yes because I don't understand
what's the point of saying that stars
are conscious but more more General
so our brains are only so big there's
only so much space inside and uh
it follows from this that there are some
things that we just won't be able to
understand
and I think we're we're actually
reaching these limits right now not not
so much in neurobiology I think there
are still a lot of stuff that we can
learn with science and also not in in
physics as I just said I'm pretty
confident that the problems the
strangeness that we see there right now
that we can ultimately explain it but we
do have big problems understanding how
to manage complex ecosystems it's just
something that doesn't fit in our head
like there are 80 billion of us on the
planet what effect do we have on the
environment we we don't really
understand it and this is why we have so
big problems uh with with our
environment but to me it always comes
back to the point like how how do we
move forward what do we do what's the
next step that we can do how can we
go beyond the limits of human cognition
and well for one it's a good idea if we
try to not go extinct but also we can
try to extend our own mind by drawing on
computers for example which we do with
artificial intelligence so I think
there's a lot of potential in this thank
you and that's a great point to move
into our second theme
um which is should we take the mysteries
of quantum mechanics and dark matter as
evidence that the universe is
incomprehensible and back to Sabina to
introduce this topic
yeah um so as I already said I think the
answers uh no
um but maybe I should step back a little
bit
um and explain why I think people
sometimes have a problem understanding
me so people often ask me uh like what
what is gravity or what does quantum
mechanics mean or do you really
understand quantum mechanics and I don't
really understand the question like for
me if I have a mathematical framework
and I can compute something that agrees
with observations that's what it means
to me to understand something and so I
think what people ask for when they ask
these questions like is there something
some a metaphor or an analogy that you
can tell me that I can map onto
something that I already know and there
are limits to this and I think that the
most obvious place where we reach those
limits is quantum mechanics there are
just things happening in quantum
mechanics
uh like the uncertainty principle or
particles that are in two places at the
same time that don't have any analogy in
our everyday life and so in in that
sense we will never be able to
intuitively understand them but we can
still understand them in terms of
mathematics thank you and I'll pass over
to Bjorn like I want to ask a question
following on from Sabinas if Sabrina's
if I understand you correctly viewer
science is if you can make all the
predictions work you can use your
equations to predict everything if you
could do that at a fundamental level and
and you knew all the equations would
that be it or is there more is there
understanding that goes beyond
predictions because ultimately a
prediction is you know electron moves
this way or electron moves that way does
that give you understanding is
prediction the same as understanding or
are we looking is there a philosophy is
there a philosophy that kind of goes
deeper and asks something Beyond making
predictions
well I would say there's uh around
limitations or limits that we are
circling around there's the obvious
sense in which we are limited by what we
know we have limited reach if we're
talking about the universe we are making
projections on the grand Cosmos based on
the tiniest spec that we inhabit uh
so we have a lack of information we have
like limits in this way but there is a
different sense in which limitation is
uh is crucial to Scientific work I think
and that's how we frame the problem in
the first place uh because how we arrive
at certain scientific whether you would
call them uh hypotheses or truths or or
whatnot is not simply uh as Rupert
referred to as a
the naked truth of reality as
mathematics reveals it it is a product
of our history and how we come to
understand the terms how we name them
how we frame them and so on so
that in itself poses limitations on how
we can understand things so uh
for me the
the answer would be that we
fundamentally cannot reach past a
certain like once we choose to frame
problem a certain way there is something
that then becomes a that framing becomes
a blind spot if you will and produces
its own set of problems but in quantum
mechanics if I understand it correctly
what we can't measure isn't really there
and I'm going to bring ruperty in to see
how you respond to that is that um well
I'd I'd rather concentrate on Dark
Matter actually because here's a case
where physicists found that galaxies
don't behave like they ought to
according to the equations of uh
gravitation so one possibility that it's
governed by something other than just
gravitation another is that
um they can make it fit their equations
and give the satisfying answer by
titrating in an unknown form of matter
called Dark Matter so the equation's
balance what does it consist of well you
just invent it to fit the equations and
of course there's no independent
evidence for it yet so this would be
satisfying from the equation point of
view but unsatisfying if you say well to
get an answer by inventing five times
more matter than we know about and just
putting it in to make the equation
balanced could possibly be just fudging
it now it so happens that there's an
alternative theory that there are
several alternative theories of galaxies
the one I like is with Greg matloff
who is a professor of physics at City
College New York an astrophysicist
he has what he calls the volitional star
hypothesis and he thinks that stars can
actually adjust their own position
within galaxies by firing out Jets we
know that the sun has flares and jets
their jet propelled and they can
actually move around to take up the
right place in the galaxy in the way
that cells take off the right place in
an embryo and you don't require Dark
Matter to explain embryology and he
thinks you don't require it to explain
Galactic structure because the stars
have a kind of autonomy and movement now
you'd never get there if you said we've
got the equations we've put in the dark
matter that makes everything balanced
and that's understanding so I think it's
been actually challenges is to think how
it actually works rather than just to
get the right answer
similar do you want to have a go at that
well one thing that dark matter has
going for it and I should probably add
I'm not the biggest fan of Dark Matter
uh but uh one thing that has going for
it is that it's a simple explanation
it's and in that sense it's good science
you need very few assumptions for dark
matter
um it's matter as the name says it
doesn't interact with light it has some
average energy density and from that you
can calculate a lot of the things that
we actually observe that's the stereo
it's a stereotypical example for a good
hypothesis now about the idea that stars
can move around in a galaxy to take put
on some position I I don't know what
observations that would really explain
like can you actually predict something
with it have you tested it yeah I was
expecting you to say that
I actually don't really want to know I
mean
so I mean this this is something that
science is really
um good at so sorting out right which
which hypothesis has the biggest uh
explanatory power and I'm a little bit
skeptical that this is going to convince
um astrophysics to try something else
can I ask Rupert uh you you uh claim or
at least proposing that stars of
Consciousness where we do have
um as as you know we have a lot a lot of
people have thought about how you test
whether say artificial intelligence
agents is conscious has anyone seen the
film Ai and um uh there's something
called the Turing test you can kind of
Converse with a computer and and if a
computer passes the Turing test so
Turing claim that you can converse with
the computer and not know that it's a
computer then you have to claim it you
have to accept that that computer is
conscious no computer I think it's
generally accepted that no computer is
as past the touring test now that's the
test that we can can actually apply
could you do it to a star
could you chat with a star and find out
whether it'll uh pass the Turing test
well um obviously I I'm just having to
speculate here but let's take the idea
you can communicate with the sun now
obviously Sabine is going to disagree
but millions of Hindus don't disagree
they say prayers they do Sun
prostrations every morning it's part of
yoga they're Central mantras the Gayatri
Mantra a prayer to the Sun to illuminate
our meditation
lots of people around the world think
the stun is conscious they offer prayers
to it and they try and communicate with
it now I'd suggest an experiment along
these lines
try and assemble large numbers of people
who believe this is possible and in
India it wouldn't be difficult to
collect uh lots of them discuss with
them what kind of things might be done
and then for example ask them to say to
the son
um the usual prayers and mantras and
then if you're conscious please give us
a sign like three solar flares in a row
or something like that some improbable
activity of solar flares and if the sun
comes back with the requested signal and
if this can be done repeatedly this
would in principle be a way of testing
for it now this is a long way off but I
should also add that it's a long way off
for any proof of dark matter or dark
energy all these other things physicists
believe in or multiverses so physics is
full of improbable and untestable
speculations actually I think this is
more testable
well if if anyone wants to fund an
experiment in India where we take
um thousands of our sun worshipers and
check this out I think we'll love to
hear about it in the next step how the
lighter gets to me could you tell them
to not send the solar flares into our
Direction
keep them in India
and we've got a little bit more time on
this uh debate another we've talked
about
um um a dark matter and I know it's you
prefer to talk about astronomical things
but the other thing is quantum mechanism
that does have some very strange aspects
like Randomness now Randomness means
that things happen at the quantum level
whether a uh a particle disintegrates or
not and in principle it's completely
random you cannot predict it now we
talked earlier that being that said that
how you understand things is you can
make predictions these are fundamentally
unpredictable there's no way it's
generally accepted you can predict how
this happens now do we understand
something if something like quantum
mechanics at a fundamental level we
can't predict why a um a particle
disintegrates because it's a quantum
mechanical entity
random variables are a well-defined
mathematical structure I don't have a
big problem with that
um of course there's the question like
is this fundamentally really what
happens like the what you said is
entirely yeah what you said is entirely
correct this is what the currently
widely accepted
standard interpretation of quantum
mechanics says is that this Randomness
is actually fundamental that's just the
way that the world is but it may not be
actually the last word you know maybe
there's a theory that underlies quantum
mechanics where we can explain what's
going on and that's certainly a
respectable Theory Einstein's one of his
most famous
pronouncements was God does not play
dice and that was because he didn't
believe that this Randomness was real
there must be some explanation for it
and I'm sure Rupert would probably have
an explanation
well no don't I think the randomness is
inherent in the structure of the whole
universe I think it's the only way that
you can have conscious causation or
other kinds of causation working if
there's indeterminacy at every level as
there is at the quantum level at the
sort of chemical level at the level of
neurophysiology there's a huge amount of
Randomness the level of the weather as
in Chaos Theory at all levels of nature
there's a Randomness that things could
go one way or another way if you have a
higher level of causation which can
impose a pattern on that Randomness then
you have a universe in which higher
levels of causation
through what I'd call I mean I think of
it through what I call morphic Fields
but
there are many other ways in which you
could have field theories or top-down
causation or conscious causation where a
pattern is imposed on otherwise random
events and unless there was a real
Randomness or Freedom or indeterminism
at every level of nature we would that
we would have a universe which was
either completely deterministic called
and random but with no possibility of
top-down causation so I think actually
it's intrinsic in the nature of things
and an isolated electron May behave in a
random way but an electron in one of the
molecules in your body is not behaving
in a random way it's behaving in a
highly coordinated way as part of that
molecule so as soon as things come
within structures the randomness is
replaced by an order which they take up
and if they break down then it's
released back to a more random state
okay thank you Rupert now we'll move on
to our third and final theme question
before we have a q a session which is
what would the consequences for us
be if we gave up on the idea that we
could uncover the essential character of
the world so I know that has been as for
example said that we can and we will and
that's her conviction but what if we
can't
are there consequences to to that
conclusion if that eventually becomes a
conclusion in science and I'll ask
Beyond to
um address that first yeah well I think
if it's uh if we ever gave it up it
would be because we would then have
figured it out I think the reason we are
not giving up is because we can't figure
it out that it's a driving force the
what we cannot understand drives us into
doing more science and philosophy uh but
I I think part of the problem with uh
this question and how this some of these
questions are are framed has to do with
the word uncovering or revealing uh this
idea which is uh intrinsic to modern
science and the history of modern
science that
emerged alongside with Christianity uh
we often have this view that it was in
uh that science and Christianity are
opposed to each other like the
pioneering scientist Galileo versus the
pope and so on but really historically
they developed side by side and were
highly complementary this idea of
Revelation was Central in both natural
philosophy of science and and in
religion at the time and this is
basically the idea that uh God writes
the book of Nature and the scientists
work is to try to decipher it and that
there is this code there's a pervasive
strand in in Western modern thought that
still exists in in parts of theoretical
physics as well that you believe you can
uncover mathematical laws are the actual
imprint of the universe as it is so
I would suggest that gets us into
trouble uh uh
because it's it suggests that we somehow
can reveal things and that there's a way
to get to a total view I think what we
are seeing and especially in the last
century is rather that science uh is a
highly creative Force science invents
things science constructs things and I
don't mean that in the sense of it's
being just the social construction but
that it's literally creating a reality
and creating a vocabulary for reality as
we go along so
I would revert back to uh the original
like the the first position that I think
science will be more like we would all
have a sound review of getting doing
better science if we can
think of take science off the pedestal
of the total View and instead think of
it how we constructively solve problems
okay thank you and Sabina do you want to
address this quote so
um yeah so so what would be the
consequences if we gave up on trying to
um resolve the strangeness well I'm
afraid that ultimately progress would
just entirely stall because what's
Driven progress for
the past 2000 years or something is that
we have understood increasingly more
about the universe and if we just let it
sit then we'll for some more we'll reap
the benefits of what we know already but
eventually we'll run out of new things
and
this will not only affect science and
technological progress but also
generally all creative processes I
always find it amazing so I have a I
have a soft spot for reading fantasy
novels and it's quite amazing how often
it's really obvious that the authors get
their inspiration from Reading popular
science articles about physics like I'm
currently reading one about magicians
don't judge me where they have a force
field and how does the force field work
well it slightly changes some of the
constants of nature like the speed of
light and the mass of the exposure so um
you see immediately where do they draw
their ideas from well it comes from
science and I think Stuart Brandt said
it very well when he said science is the
only news which is maybe overstating the
point a little bit but I think in
principle it's right we get these really
new Big Ideas from science can I also
ask you to address kind of the reverse
question here what if science did do a
Sabina projects it will and explained
everything everything you could predict
is the room for God is there room for
philosophy if you can do it all with
equations where then and I'll ask up
because you guys suspect I'll ask Rupert
to address that first so let's imagine
that Sabina is right and we can predict
everything at uh down to the absolute
level limits of quantum mechanics
is there room for anything else
philosophy metaphysics well I mean the
the leads us straight into the
philosophy of mathematics doesn't it and
traditionally
um in in Western philosophy mathematics
and came out of the Pythagorean and
platonic Traditions that mathematics is
in the mind of God it's in an ideal
world that transcends the physical
universe and that's why the laws of
nature are present everywhere at all
times immutable omnipotent they have all
the qualities of God because they're
part of the Divine mind that was how the
founders of modern science saw it as
well
um and so what's happened in in modern
physics is people have rubbed out God
but they're left with these
free-floating laws of nature and many
mathematicians whether they'd admit it
or not a secret platonists and Roger
Penrose is an actual explicit places
um and uh so in other words they believe
there's a mathematical realm that's
totally Transcendent on which this world
depends and which it reflects now that's
a form of Theology and I personally
think it's a very limited form of
theology because I think the mind of God
contains a lot more than mathematics
um and so I think if we have the idea of
a Divine mind containing potentially all
forms and potentially all creativity
through the ongoing creative action in
the Christian tradition of the Holy
Spirit tomorrow is the Festival of the
Holy Spirit Whitson or Pentecost
um the the we have a creative action
working through nature which is uh
Divine in origin and I think it's quite
possible to integrate uh theology both
Christian Hindu and and other forms of
theology with the scientific worldview
in a way that enriches both that's my
own personal View and perhaps not shared
by many but I think it makes most sense
of these things and if we don't have
something like that we're left with
free-floating mathematical laws with no
ontological basis at all as the basis of
our description of the universe which I
think is incoherent what do you guys
think do we need if mathematics explains
everything do we need to explain
mathematics does there have to be a
metaphysical space out there that gives
the power of mathematics
I think it's impossible to do
mathematics without having set out some
sort of limitation or ground assumption
before you get started there is not if
you look at Einstein's uh book on
relativity
he starts off by outlining you know
there's a few assumptions like
principles of special relativity and
principle equivalence and so on and then
you get into a whole lot of mathematics
usually I think physicists that are
trained more on the mathematical side
they skip past the assumptions and say
okay how can I make this work and then
you start calculating
to my mind it's a delusion that you
could ever understand things purely
mathematically I also believe like
Rupert that's a theological idea of the
core
Sabina
so I'm not entirely sure that I would
agree it's theological but it may come
as a shock to some of you but I partly
agree with what you said a lot of
physicists who
um are platonists and they don't really
understand that this is not a scientific
position and it's it's not a good thing
if they conflate their beliefs with the
science but to come back to the question
like do we have to explain mathematics I
actually think that we reach our limits
before we even talk about where
mathematics comes from if we just look
at what we can explain with physics so
you made it sound as if I think that we
can actually at some point explain
everything I don't think so I think that
whenever we have some theory that
explains our observations we'll always
be left with questions about the theory
like why this Theory why not some other
Theory and I think that some of those
questions will ultimately be impossible
to answer because part of the answer
will always just be because it explains
what we observe agreement from our panel
so on that note
panel
[Applause]